FIFA the almighty Soccer Federation has
finally been dealt a bombshell of a red
card the US Department of Justice the
FBI and the IRS have come after it in a
way usually reserved for international
terror cases or drug cartels 7 FIFA
officials were arrested in a swanky
Zurich hotel facing charges of money
laundering wire fraud and international
racketeering in addition to accepting
millions of dollars in bribes 14 people
in total were indicted with possibly
more to come now if you followed FIFA
scandals over the years
none of this should come as a total
surprise don't believe me here are 5
ways that FIFA is pretty effed up
corruption is to FIFA as greed is to
Wall Street they corrupted the business
of worldwide soccer to serve their
interests and to enrich themselves some
of the charges include buying and
selling votes to deliver the 2010 World
Cup to South Africa alleged bribes to
hold the 2016 Copa America in the US and
more bribes paid to FIFA execs for
exclusive TV and marketing contracts the
DOJ says that 150 million dollars in
bribes and kickbacks go all the way back
to 1991 oh and did I mention that FIFA
is a non profit down FIFA president Sepp
Blatter has long did Slim for running
the organization like a corrupt dictator
he's been president of people since 1998
and is going for his fifth term blador's
quadrupled FIFA's revenue during his
tenure but many say he's done this by
buying votes suppressing dissent and
rewarding Boyle T with cash and hand
outs you name it he's done it all you'd
think the latest FIFA drama would be the
closest we get to bladders downfall
since this but despite the calls for him
to resign he refuses to be toppled FIFA
generates billions of dollars in profits
especially during the World Cup but they
do so by imposing the costs of the Cup
on the host countries all the while
pocketing much of the profits football
is a way of life in Brazil but many
Brazilians felt that FIFA exploited them
think of money as pubic hair and FIFA as
waxed
they're gonna be all over you during the
World Cup but when they go they're
taking all the money with them including
some from places you didn't even know
you had any money the Brazilian
government spent around eleven billion
dollars in preparation for the 2014
World Cup that many believe should have
gone to schools roads and healthcare
instead the Brazilians were left with a
whole lot of debt and massive Ixion's
but FIFA's saga isn't just about rich
men making themselves richer there's a
human toll too features corruption both
Russia and Qatar were awarded the 2018
and 2022 World Cups respectively
something the Swiss government is now
investigating due to suspicions of
drives then there are the human rights
concerns in Qatar which is bracing to
build stadiums in time for the games
1,200 South Asian laborers have died
since 2010 due to heat exhaustion and
unfair working conditions an
investigation said that at least 4,000
people are projected to die before the
2022 World Cup even kicks off Russia
plans to use prisoners to build out the
World Cup infrastructure and bring down
costs but despite all these concerns
FIFA says the games will go on in both
countries
and last but certainly not least you
can't forget about the women even though
FIFA sorta does Alex Morgan one of the
most recognizable faces in women's
soccer says she was shocked at an event
where she was being honored as one of
the top three players in the world
because Sepp Blatter didn't even
recognize her not surprising coming from
the dude who suggested that female
players wear tighter shorts to attract
more viewers then you have the literal
unequal playing field the Women's World
Cup heads to Canada in June but rather
than playing on grass like the boys
women are forced to play on artificial
turf which slows down the game and
causes more injuries but hey at least
the popular FIFA video game will now
allow women to play thankfully on grass
there you have it five of FIFA's biggest
Follies over the years so given all of
this drama compete this reputation ever
bounced back